lavate i ragazzi uno di questi la
situazione pensavo su the night away
allora ho letto al volo la trama che
carino questo cetino nell'angolo
semplicemente credo che sia un oro a
quanto ho capito credo che sia un horror
dove devo tornare a casa ecco presso usd
chiesto comunque va bene questa è la
ragazza tra un passo incredibile cioè
camminando fa fa un kilowatt sei marce
jacobs va in creme fai questo fai 100
metri una maniera incredibile roba
pazzesca record del mondo messi ai
sciolga i confess lo tornare a casa
presto sì sì certo non ho mai visto dei
muri in giappone così sporchi la prima
volta che è successo è già un urp a te
non c'è nessuno è sta roba troppo
irreale ma lavora tutto occorre sta
tizia fantastico se mi sa che qualcuno
sono posto dove cacchio sto andando
vorrei una bibita per favore si può no
non li s chi è che si sta annunciando il
culetto going irish aid salve dice che
cosa l'abbia krier grazie mille che ve
lo dice il gioco che non avevo notato
ahi ahi ok al giusto
mix
ergo o no
macché dialogo di merda voglio andare a
casa non è anche vogliate la casa o che
bello non vogliamo andare a casa magari
tisti corsi giorno cosa piangi smettila
abbiamo smesso di piangere
mia solo mia distrutto il polso che
succede o mia sfogato tutta la mano ma
cosa si perché hai fatto questa cosa
tanto cosa c'è un cric al posto della
mano che rumor affatto hayward che cosa
è successo devo andare a casa va bene io
non mi faccio più domande bois dark
times che i fusti in the dark fortwo
long dei ritmi teheran se ti dà dopo
quel estiva proprio perché dice un coso
dell'ansia che devo tenere basso e la
madonna c'è su di qua a un detto from
the west lockerby di qua 389 1278 980
questo male ricordare ci faccio la foto
ragazzi e ciò c'è la cosa del telefono
la cala la democrazia cioè il telefono
fisso ma non
mi scusi ma dov'era spari è sparito in
tutto ciò
panic
[Musica]
ceca aiuto tanto di più quanto grossi va
beh ma stai perché perché animale è
questo verso che stai facendo per me
abbiamo quanto veloce pazzesca e
velocissima incredibile sono porta ma
sono ancora vivo
devo tornare in bagno che non ci passa
dalla porta non solo era il bagno però
eccolo
ma ci passi non ci passi dai non potendo
poi traguardo sei troppo troppo alta non
ci passi meno male che tecnica ragazzi è
stata una roba orribile se posso essere
sincero prova bene se ne andrà quindi il
bagno è l'unico posto in cui posso
defilarmi in questo caso va bene
madonna è stato orribile
ma quanto grossa poi ma chi è
guarda che ho trovato il numero un corso
di telefono 15 il numero 4 chiuso a ieri
ho fatto la foto per niente anche tanto
c'era già segnato pronto pronto
pronti tre grazie è stato utile molto
veramente utile ma la chiave nel top
locker
ma dove andare e trevi trovarlo quel
punto fu caps colori trovo
però mai
cacchio era se ne va beh prima che
ritrovo quella roba lì ce piego 60 anni
la tipa ella mi pareva che fosse tipo di
quattro
prove regina che io la seguo la zia
perché secondo me dove passa lei poi non
passa più spiega torna indietro
ma perché mio padre non so perché nella
mia testa io ho deciso un giorno che lo
inizia a parlare ma perché eccolo l'ho
trovato security ronchi
prendi la
e la prende hanno preso che prefetto non
l'ho preso prendi la che problemi hai
zia ceva l'ho presa lo perciò messo due
ore ma lo prendo un suo cometra
e non mi ricordo dove la porta se non
rendo
andare avanti economico sia la porta
ragazzi già passata a due ore ecco qua
no che è usala
yes
yes giuria porta perfetto bene sono al
sicuro anche con nonni data poi ci passa
perché la portella ormai fini ha posto
open days in shutter
ho aperto l'uscita non so dove aperto
già perché questa è la porta del locale
manutenzione non so dove l'ho aperto
l'uscita ma l'ho sentita di qua credo di
avere aperto luci non ne sono
sicurissimo è
lì dove si è riuscita marito ha più o
meno
la zia è sparita completamente eccola
ok
vado di qua piano piano
mix comprano va avanti perché dovrebbe
essere qua destra corretto o pazzini
hanno quella è uscita questa è uscita
alle scotte
per in ice e si esce proprio lui madonna
ragazzi che roba è stato ha definita
adesso forse questo gioco no che cos'è
che sta succedendo devo prendere la mia
bici
per forse non era nel basement devo
andare a casa in fretta c'è nel basement
sta la bici in cantina ottimo comunque
non c'è nessuno in giro sai cosa è
veramente super criti save programs
grazie che lo farà partire
la vanno a cercare un bel basement dove
andare a trovare amici che poi prendere
la macchina è un po strano che comunque
le macchine siano totalmente senza gente
non lo so io mi farei due domande io
sono leggenda che è successo
kat c'era il abc dove puoi parcheggiare
una bici nel basement cioè io santo
iddio non so come faccio ancora giocare
a sta roba
c'e nel bain mentre parcheggia la bici
no io io io non posso fare stabilità
cioè dal vivo io questa via questa vita
non la faccio più basta basta fare
giochi horror basta basta giochiamo
altra roba giochiamo a hello kitty ma
cosa c'è io veramente ho preso io non
dopo adesso 40 anni cioè come un come ho
fatto dove cazzola e mezza la bicicletta
ma vai a piedi che sei più veloci usain
bolt
quello di in panico ogni volta che sta
fra 18 e 18 per l'amor di dio
ce n'è una per piano no dai non so come
faccio a fare sta roba cazzola metti la
vinci tu porco del demonio di qua guarda
guarda marchi giri che non fare
il lavaggio della macchina devo fare
altro poma dove minchia è parcheggiato
st bicicletta santo gesù fatti sembra
che comportato nei questo dove la puoi
mettere una bicicletta ma sei matta
[Musica]
io questa vita non la faccio mi rifiuto
hanno compiuto una grossa riva
è la zia devo uscire di qua non so come
adesso dovrò fare la forza
c'è una porta
è completamente chiuso io sono i mega
panico non so come
detti l'agenda di panico santo iddio
tema dove vado su e poi ha detto
ci sono passato non solo 20 madonna è
proprio una bici da un milione di
dollari sarei parcheggiata così perché
ci hai povertà potessero potevo andare
quando c'è la luce le sono mentre nel
panico ok
ma ecco che non insegna con una bici che
non ci credo guarda un parcheggio di
merda delle biciclette dall'altra parte
del pianeta veramente prevista
camionette vattene
sia qualcosa no
abbiamo
adesso che ciò la mia canio bolide sono
cazzi suoi e cosa sto giocando ragazzi
per l'amor di dio vi prego stop ai piani
non c'è chi la tua bici anche peccato
semi agendo cosa che sta facendo
questo step perché stai piace mai bike
da una [ __ ] bass
attenzione colpo di scena
e succede
exit parking lot li hanno [ __ ] la
bici che peccato peccato perché non
potresti mica prenderne un'altra vista
la situazione no no devo andare alla
fermata dell'autobus
ovviamente visto che non c'è un
cristiano i 12 chilometri quadrati che
hai fatto mi sembra giusto andare al
parcheggio dell'auto perché sicuramente
passerà l'autobus o usa vuole stesso
vuole sarei per il re pellux feel to
expect o patronum no niente ha
illuminato illumina perché tutti butto
via gli spiriti bel figo è implicata nel
panico in cicli motivo di panico
il santo è successo quando simpatica va
più veloce ma il meno male che c'è il
panico mi ha chiamato più veloce del
normale
avere preso bob arum nicchi ha
funzionato bellissimo ad avercela avuta
prima sta roba come
una donna di dio questo expect o patron
un male sarà molto più veloce la zia
dov'è la fermata dell'autobus è
esattamente se posso chiedere michiara
zia era net e usain bolt 2 non so dove
sto andando spero che la fermata
dell'autobus siamo vicino perché sono
autobus stop
presente questa in panico ma non vedo
dove di garmisch
è veramente ci fa
scusi è qualcosa ho capito dove mi ha
detto che vado poi non c'è la mappa
enorme suo posto come cacchio faccio io
a capire dovevo andarmene ragazzi
conclude il primo episodio di anahi cioè
una notte chi a casa ci vediamo nel
prossimo perché sono due episodi molto
carino questo gioco spero vi stia
piacendo fa pensare che metti che ne
pensate procediamo poi sempre al
prossimo visto bene ragazzi
[Musica]
ma